herzlich willkommen zur folge 186 das
faz einspruch podcast das wöchentlichen
podcast der faz für recht justiz und
politik heute am 17 november
2021 mein name ist corinna budras ich
bin berlin korrespondentin faz und mit
dabei ist wie immer bei lorenz mann aus
köln ich bin freier journalist und
jurist in der appia wir können gleich
mal anfangen womit wir heute nicht
anfangen oder das finde ich gut ist ja
immer ein guter einstieg was wir heute
nicht machen ist corona aus dem
einfachen grund alle sind genervt nein
das ist nicht ganz der grund natürlich
sind alle genervt aber wir dachten uns
wir haben euch jetzt wirklich
hinreichend abgedrehte die letzten zwei
wochen über die möglichen pläne der
möglichen ampelkoalition ehre und da
sich ja voraussichtlich in dieser woche
nun wirklich mal vieles final
entscheiden wird und man ja zum teil
auch gar nicht mehr so richtig hinterher
kommt impfpflicht für bestimmte berufe
ja nein vielleicht doch nicht haben wir
uns entschlossen das lassen wir jetzt
einfach mal beiseite und informieren
euch darüber in der kommenden woche wenn
dann hoffentlich auch mal mehr fest
steht genau und wir haben ja viele
schöne andere themen wir beginnen
nämlich mit einer weiteren folge in
unserer serie
verzweifelte versuche der großstädte die
mietpreissteigerung in den griff zu
bekommen
seien wir doch mal ehrlich es geht doch
wieder um berlin ja natürlich auch aber
eben nicht nur das was wir hier
berichten werden findet auch in köln und
münchen zum beispiel statt und ich es
bleibt übrigens nicht bei den
verzweifelten suchen versuchen sondern
wir beschreiben auch ihr scheitern vor
den bundesgerichten diesmal konkret das
vorkaufsrecht der kommunen so und dann
gab es vergangene woche einen durchbruch
in den langjährigen bemühungen der eu
den großen digital konzern mal zur
abwechslung ein paar fesseln anzulegen
jenseits des datenschutzes geht ja auch
darum die marktmacht zu brechen ja von
google
facebook und co und das europäische
gericht hat google zu einer ersten
rekordstrafe verurteilt auch das kann es
keinesfalls das ende vom lied und die eu
hat da noch wie es nicht mehr in petto
und das bespreche ich mit dem
eu-abgeordneten andreas schwab von der
svp-fraktion der übrigens auch
berichterstatter des digital markets
acts ist ich bin sehr gespannt was herr
schwab dazu sagt ob das jetzt
tatsächlich der erste schritt ist um die
macht der großkonzerne zu brechen ich
bin gespannt dann haben wir eine hübsche
kleine bgh entscheidung zu einem
ehemaligen hengeler referendar also der
in der großkanzlei hengeler mueller war
und deshalb jetzt nicht über große
verfahren entscheiden darf wegen
befangenheit
wir haben zwei nachträge die mehr oder
weniger schön sind und wir haben vor
allem in dieser woche gleich zwei
gerechte urteile und für den total
unwahrscheinlichen fall dass eine oder
einer von euch ansonsten vor den
gerechten urteilen aussteigt wir können
davon diese woche nur dringend abraten
beide urteile sind echt cool aber das
zweite ist wirklich der mega ich möchte
zitieren was gucken an unser
vorbereitendes dokument geschrieben hat
klar die jungs kommen nach häuser auf in
den knast so ihr wisst ihr bescheid und
zwar nicht nur klare jungs und nicht nur
häuser raub sondern auch noch ein anwalt
des beteiligt ein dubioser geschäftsmann
ist eine völlig irre geschichte es lohnt
sich mega bis zum schluss ganz bleich
ich muss ergänzen kleinen jungs kommen
theoretisch in haft also auch da gibt es
stimmt natürlich auch wieder ärger von
der bild aber das klären wir alles
gleich
[Musik]
und steigen jetzt ein mit dem
bundesverwaltungsgericht das in der
vergangenen woche die verkaufspraxis bei
grundstücken in milieus schutzgebieten
gestoppt hat es ging natürlich ich habe
es schon angedeutet um ein berliner
verfahren es sind aber auch ganz viele
andere städte betroffen denn wir reden
von einem echten grundsatzurteil gucken
erzählt genau also da geht es um einen
besonderen ideenreichtum ich hatte es am
anfang schon erwähnt wie man versucht
dem
mietpreissteigerungen ja herr zu werden
in den bezirken und man versucht dazu
dass es städte baurecht zu nutzen und
dass dieser versuch muss man sagen es
krachend gescheitert dabei klang er doch
vielleicht eigentlich sogar ganz gut es
geht um ein vorkaufsrecht und wie etwa
der bezirke wie funktioniert das also
hier in dem konkreten fall geht es um
einen altbau im friedrichshain kreuzberg
friedrichshain und zwar ein
mehrfamilienhaus aus dem jahr 1889 mit
20 mietwohnungen und zwei
gewerbeeinheiten so und dieses haus
sollte jetzt verkauft wäre genau das
sollte verkauft werden an eine
immobiliengesellschaft und bei solchen
konstellation grätscht in diesen
bezirken der das bezirksamt ja ja fast
automatisch sein und guckt sich das
genauer an warum krise bezirke sind
bezirke die unter million schutz stehen
richtig genau richtung der richtig da
geht eben die milieus satzung etwas
juristischer formuliert ist es die dem
schutz der erhaltung der zusammensetzung
der wohnbevölkerung aus besonderen
städtebaulichen gründen dient also auf
deutsch gesagt es geht darum das nicht
nicht ganz so finanzkräftige menschen
vertrieben werden durch gentrifizierung
durch luxussanierungen und so weiter
richtig also das typische berliner
problem das natürlich in berlin
besonders ausgeprägt ist aber in allen
anderen großstädten also auch vor ganz
genau und wie funktioniert das konkret
also das bezirksamt hat daneben da die
möglichkeit rein zu grätschen und dann
dem
immobilienkäufer da bestimmte auflagen
zu machen bzw denen eine abwendung
vereinbarung aufzudrücken ja was steht
da drin da stehen eben drin dass sich
der reigen der neue eigentümer dazu
verpflichtet und zwar für 20 jahre lang
die nicht umzuwandeln in also die
mietwohnung nicht umzuwandeln in
eigentumswohnungen und auch sanierung
wertsteigernde sanierungen die dann zu
höheren mietpreisen führen sind nicht
erlaubt ja also damit verpflichtet sich
der immobilienkäufer diese dinge
einzuhalten und interessanterweise
übrigens geht es da durchaus auch um
energetische sanierung ja also das
klingt ja natürlich irgendwie auch alles
ganz nett und nachvollziehbar wenn man
eben versucht sozusagen völlig
explodierende mieten zu verhindern auf
der an seiner seite ist natürlich 20
jahre auch echten massiv langer zeitraum
und das bedeutet ja dann auch dass man
solange auch nicht modernisieren würde
all diese gebäude
und wenn sich dann der käufer nicht
darauf einlässt das ist übrigens dann
auch so eine vereinbarung die sogar im
grundbuch eingetragen wird und wenn sich
der käufer da nicht drauf
einlässt dann hat bisher eben die
kommune konnte die von ihrem
vorkaufsrecht gebrauch machen und dann
ihm für die landeseigene immobilien
gesellschaft da ein paar millionen
hinlegen ja das ist ja alles nicht ganz
kostengünstig und dann war auf einmal
eben nicht der eigentliche käufer
derjenige der sich über denen die ihr
freuen konnte sondern eben die
landeseigene immobilien gesellschaft das
ist hier aber dann eben nicht passiert
sondern der käufer hat gesagt ich will
diese vereinbarung nicht ob diese
abfindungsvereinbarung nicht abgeben ich
ziehe das jetzt durch und ist durch die
instanzen gezogen ist durch die
instanzen gezogen hat auch in der
vorinstanz noch recht bekommen aber dann
ging es eben zum
bundesverwaltungsgericht
und die haben sich ehrlich gesagt
einfach nur mal den gesetzeswortlaut
angeguckt also bitter es ist
so margraf 24 ford folgende des
baugesetzbuches sind eben die dinge die
man dann aufschlagen muss da ist das
vorkaufsrecht geregelt und dazu muss man
wissen dass dient eigentlich dazu
unbebaute
grundstücke zum beispiel jetzt endlich
mal zu bebauen und die nicht einfach so
brach liegen zu lassen also wenn man da
sieht da verwildert quasi ein grundstück
an das bezirksamt da eintreten und dann
eben sagen wir kaufen uns den kram damit
er endlich mal diese fläche hier nutzen
können das ist eigentlich der klassische
fall oder so so geisterhäuser und so ein
zeug also die dann irgendwie der
klassiker erbengemeinschaft man kann
sich auch nichts ändern und dann steht
hat mitten in der city ein riesiges haus
das langsam vor sich hin verfällt und
mit dem nichts passiert in dem jemand
lebt so soll verhindert werden und hier
war ging es eben einfach darum dass in §
26 absatz 4 sogar eigentlich
bestandsimmobilien komplett ausgenommen
waren von diesem vorkaufsrecht und da
hatten die richter eigentlich vor allen
dingen
das den gesetzestext gelesen und genauso
muss man das leider ja richtig also das
steht wirklich einfach relativ eindeutig
drin es gibt kein vorkaufsrecht wenn das
grundstück entsprechend den zielen oder
zwecken der städtebaulichen maßnahmen
bebaut ist und genutzt wird und wenn es
keine missstände oder mängel gibt punkt
ja und hier ist es eben einfach so jetzt
war auch das in der literatur übrigens
auch relativ und in den vorinstanzen
auch relativ umstrittene also man hatte
schon den wunsch dass durchzudrücken und
dann hat wurde eben immer gefragt
inwieweit können denn die absichten des
erwerbers also und auch über die
prognosen darüber wieder sich jetzt in
zukunft verhält ob der tatsächlich die
mieten erhöht und so weiter inwieweit
das erkannt dass eine rolle spielen und
die guten geister dann immer versucht da
rein zu interpretieren aber dem
erweiterungs richter haben ganz klar
gesagt nee da können wir uns leider
nicht darauf einlassen also wenn der
gesetzgeber das regeln möchte kann das
gerne tun aber hat es bisher nicht getan
und deswegen können wir diese norm hier
dafür nicht nutzen so genau das
bundesverwaltungsgericht hat jetzt
relativ deutlich gesagt es geht um den
zeitpunkt der entscheidung wo jetzt also
die behörde entscheidet das
vorkaufsrecht ja nein vielleicht und
nicht darum was ein potenzieller käufer
in zehn jahren tun könnte
so und jetzt ist natürlich die große
frage also das ist war er war eine
entscheidung die schon auf große
resonanz gestoßen ist auch auf viel
kritik nehrung gesagt hat jetzt wird den
kommunen auch noch diese möglichkeit aus
den händen geschlagen und man muss sagen
das ist also zumindest in berlin aber
ich denke das wird auch in anderen
kommunen der bei seinen anderen
großstädten der faser potenziell ja
viele wohnungen betreffen kann also war
angebauten dritte hier in berlin könnte
das betreffende wenn sie denn verkauft
werden dann natürlich erst dann kann das
bezirksamt rein grätsche auf der anderen
seite ist das natürlich auch immer
wahnsinnig teuer man kann sich auch
fragen ob das so sinnvoll ist das
bezirksamt oder als eben eine klamme
stadt berlin da mal rein gerutscht und
dann den kram lieber selber kauf der
also das kann es auch eigentlich nicht
sein wobei übrigens auch der anwalt karl
stefan schwär von der kanzlei raum mit
dem habe ich mich da gestern länger
darüber unterhalten schöne grüße gehen
raus es war nicht auch wer erhält der
auch noch mal deutlich gemacht hat ist
ja nicht so als könne jetzt die die
kommunen gar nichts mehr machen da also
schon jetzt sind es ist ja so dass diese
sanierung ja genehmigungspflichtig sind
ja also schon jetzt können eigentlich
die in diesem milieu schutzgebieten die
bezirke ziemlich deutlich die
marschrichtung vorgeben und auch den
käufern da die sache
vorschreiben und und jedenfalls genauer
regeln ja was da zu tun und was vor
allen dingen zu lassen ist und das
findet er reicht aus er hat jetzt auch
noch mal ins spiel gebracht was das
eigentlich bedeutet für die ganzen
abwendung vereinbarung die jetzt ja
schon geschlossen wurden ja auf basis
eines nicht wirksam vorkaufsrecht sind
die jetzt eigentlich alle obsolet ja
also das wird man dann auch sehen müssen
ob sich da jetzt nicht noch etliche
verfahren anschließen naja ich meine da
fühlen sich jetzt die käufer und
investoren natürlich darauf berufen
möglicherweise sagte können sie jetzt
gekündigt werden wenn das vorkaufsrecht
gar nicht bestand naja also letztlich
natürlich bereits umgesetzte verkäufe
betrifft das natürlich nicht mehr da
muss jetzt nichts rückabgewickelt werden
oder so aber für die gegend stehen jetzt
wahrscheinlich alles mal mindestens auf
dem prüfstand was auch schon
abgeschlossen wurde neben entschuldige
bitte hier das ist sozusagen der punkt
für abgeschlossene verkäufe in denen die
abwendung vereinbarung geschlossen
wurden also in dem der der cholera die
immobiliengesellschaft sich verpflichtet
hat auf 20 jahre im grünbuch auch
festgehaltene keine sanierungen mehr
vorzunehmen die frage ist sozusagen muss
er sich daran jetzt noch gebunden fühlen
okay da
und daran könnte sich jetzt noch ein
bisschen was anknüpfen
und wie gesagt in zukunft wird das
jedenfalls für bestandsimmobilien
diese möglichkeit des vorkaufsrecht es
nicht geben es sei denn der gesetzgeber
die ampel parteien die möglicherweise
bald eine koalition form grätschen da
rein also
eine arge schlappe für die kommunen und
das ist auch fast schon ein bisschen
bedauerlich für berlin finde ich also
ich meine berlin gibt sich ja immer aus
gegebenen anlass und gutem grund noch
wirklich mühe kreativ zu werden um
irgendwie den die mieten wahnsinn zu
stoppen und er leitet dann halt immer
bei der bundesverwaltung soll bei den
bundesgerichten doch relativ wiese
schlappen aber auch schon wegen dingen
die ja doch auch schon im gesetz stehen
muss man auch mal sagen ja und von denen
ich jetzt auch nicht hundertprozentig
überzeugt bin dass sie in das sie
wirksamkeit entfalten also wir haben
hier übrigens das noch mal das müssen
wir gar nicht vertiefen aber die
tatsache dass sogar energetische
sanierung ausgeschlossen sind damit
laufen wir auf einen grandiosen
zielkonflikt hinaus
also im gebäudesektor das ist ja der
einzige sektor der im vergangenen jahr
auch die
zielvorgaben nicht erfüllt hat für die
reduktion die co2 reduktion die
treibhausgas-reduktion ja und also das
ist ein riesiges riesiges feld und dann
ist haben wir natürlich immer also auch
schon seit jahren mit einem clash der
unterschiedlichen bedürfnisse zu tun
einerseits vernünftigen klimaschutz auf
der anderen seite haben wir die mieter
interessen also das sind riesige
verteilungskämpfe die da wahrscheinlich
noch geführt werden die wir jetzt nur
quasi ankratzen können aber das wird
auch noch mal spannend wie das in
nächster zeit weiter geht und wie gesagt
ob jetzt so eine landeseigene
gesellschaft
die die also das nonplusultra ist also
im grunde genommen die lösung für das
problem in berlin weiß ich ja auch immer
nicht gesagt nicht ich auch nicht keine
abschließende meinung dazu problem zu
komplex und vermutlich wenn man versucht
das eine zu lösen wird man immer mit
einem anderen kollidieren ja deswegen
können wir doch jedoch einfach mal einen
schlussstrich ziehen
ja und dann kommen wir jetzt nach europa
genau du hast nicht nur mit herrn
schwarz gesprochen sondern wir werden
euch noch ein bisschen einführen in das
thema nämlich das europäische gericht
hat ein mega bußgeld gegen google
verhält 2,42 milliarden euro weil die
google-suchmaschine dem hauseigenen
preisvergleichsdienst google shopping
einen unrechtmäßigen wettbewerbsvorteil
verschafft habe und damit google genauer
gesagt alfabet das ist ja der mutter
konzern seine marktbeherrschende
stellung auf dem markt der suchmaschinen
ausgenutzt hat
2,42 milliarden des neuen sagen naja ich
finde das immer so ein bisschen erst
wenn das ja auch so ein großartiges
spannungsfeld nur weil wenn man ein
google denkt und vor allen dingen die
vorwürfe die google und auch den großen
digital konzern gemacht werden denkt man
natürlich nicht zuerst eines shopping
vergleichsportalen und wie schlimm das
irgendwie da ist und wie sehr der kunde
da bleibt wird oder wie auch immer man
das formulieren möchte ja aber ist es
interessanterweise wirklich ja auch nur
ein stein ein baustein in dem krampf
sozusagen weil diese marktmacht der
digital konzerne zu brechen dass es auch
nur ein verfahren von mehreren
verfahrens sind insgesamt über acht
milliarden die die eu-kommission
verhängt hat das war jetzt sozusagen das
erste was ist mal zu einem urteil jetzt
gebracht hat den ja noch weitere aus wie
er hat mir auch im herbst jetzt ich
glaube im september gab es eine ganze
woche wo verhandelt wurde über einen
anderen fall wo es tatsächlich um diese
ganzen android verfahren geht das ist ja
das zweite
spiel fällt auf dem es immer wieder
klappt gibt also wenn man sich google
anguckt hat die eu-kommission schon
einiges
versucht versucht und den vorzuwerfen
was man sagen also vielleicht um das
noch einmal deutlich zu machen in dem
verfahren du hast das schon gesagt geht
es um die marktbeherrschende stellung in
diesem bereich von google das ist ein
verfahren das 2008 übrigens schon begann
wurde also der jedenfalls bis dahin
reichen die vorwürfe
2010 gab es die erste entscheidung und
das zog sich und zog sich und zog sich
und da kann man ja schon mal nachfragen
ob das alles so wahnsinnig effektiv ist
was die eu kommission gegenüber den
den digital konzern anzubieten hat und
dann rutschen wir doch gleich mal jetzt
unser interview der woche
heute ist andreas schwab unser gast er
sitzt seit nunmehr 17 jahren für die cdu
als abgeordneter im europaparlament
korrekter weise muss man ja sagen für
die cvp fraktion herzlich willkommen
herr schwarz guten morgen frau budras
sie sind für unseren podcast ja schon
aus zwei gründen qualifiziert herr
schwab zum einen sind sie
berichterstatter bei einem drittel
markets act kennen also die pläne der eu
für die regulierung die geht der digital
konzerne sehr sehr gut darüber wollen
wir gleich sprechen und außerdem
bezeichnet sie das
online-nachrichtenportal politiker als
googles big ist froh als googles größter
feind im europaparlament fühlen sie sich
damit hinreichend beschrieben nein
überhaupt nicht ich glaube das ist bei
der frage wie wir die digitale welt
regeln wie wir sie auch im einzelfall
regulieren nichts mit der gegnerschaft
zu einzelnen unternehmen zu tun haben
kann sondern dafür ein
breites wertegerüst notwendig ist und
dieses wertegerüst hat die freiburger
schule mit der sozialen marktwirtschaft
geschaffen und wir wollen gemeinsam mit
der europäischen kommission dafür sorgen
dass die prinzipien der sozialen
marktwirtschaft im digitalen zeitalter
eben nicht unter die räder kommen
sondern die prinzipien die uns im
offline rahmen stark und unser leben und
unsere gesellschaften gerecht gemacht
haben auch im digitalen zeitalter weiter
gelten das ist jedenfalls das ziel für
das ich kämpfe
das ist sie sagen im grunde haben sie
machen nur ihre arbeit
so kann man zusammenfassen aber ich weiß
dass es heutzutage in zeiten von social
media nicht mehr besonders sexy ist
vielleicht beginnen wir mal mit dem
google verfahren oder besser gesagt mit
den google verfahren denn das sind ja
mehrere vergangene woche kam das erste
urteil im google kartellverfahren wie
würden sie das bewerten meilenstein oder
längst überfällig
es ist schwer zu sagen denn das
verfahren bis jetzt vor dem europäischen
gericht abgeschlossen wurde ist ja
gewissermaßen die bestätigung einer
entscheidung der europäischen kommission
aus dem jahr 2017 und dieses verfahren
bis 2017 durch die europäische
kommission mit der entscheidung geändert
hat begann ja bereits kurz nach 2010
heißt wir haben insgesamt jetzt eben
über elf jahre ein verfahren zu einem
abschluss vor gericht gebracht wenn man
das bei der unglaublich schnellen
entwicklung im digitalen zeitalter als
meilenstein bezeichnen wollte dann wären
wir schnecken im camp um alles und
deswegen kann es nicht ganz so positiv
sehen aber es ist die bestätigung dass
die vorgehen und die vorgehensweise der
europäischen kommission
gerichtsfest sind und das sollte uns
selbstbewusstsein geben wo liegen denn
das ihrer sicht eigentlich die
schwierigkeiten sind die verfahren
einfach zu komplex sie haben jetzt zu
recht gesagt das hat elf jahre gedauert
oder ist das kartellrecht diesen
internetgiganten nicht gewachsen
also die erste analyse ist sicher dass
die moderne verwaltung
weit technisch und auch intellektuell
den entwicklungen in silicon valley
hinterher hängt und deswegen sehr sehr
viel zeit braucht um überhaupt zu
verstehen welche technischen und
algorithmischen möglichkeiten die
unternehmen nutzen um märkte zu
entwickeln und anschließend auch neue
märkte zu ergattern
zum zweiten ist es so dass unser
rechtliches instrumentarium im
europäischen wettbewerbsrecht eben die
beweislast bei der europäischen
kommission mit die behörde sieht sie
muss nachweisen dass eine
marktbeherrschende stellung bestand sie
muss dem markt definieren auf dem diese
beherrschende stellung durch ein
unternehmen oder einen dienst bestand
und das kann gelingen es dauert aber
unter den bereits beschriebenen
bedingungen seine zeit und dadurch dass
diese märkte so unglaublich schnell und
flexibel sind können die unternehmen
natürlich dann auch während der
untersuchung die lange dauert ihre
praktiken ändern und insofern er ist die
europäische kommission sind die
nationalen kartellbehörden lange den
entwicklungen hinterher gerannt und das
wollen wir jetzt ja genau auch durch den
diebstahl markets act ändern dass
nämlich die unternehmen künftig
nachweisen müssen dass ihre
geschäftspraktiken die prinzipien des
europäischen wettbewerbsrechts beachten
und nicht die europäische kommission
nachweisen muss dass diese unternehmen
diese prinzipien verletzt haben genau da
kommen wir gleich nach zu wie wer ist
denn eigentlich auch ein problem das ja
bei google die sache mal ein bisschen
anders liegt also im normalen
kartellverfahren wir haben jetzt ja hier
damit zu tun mit einem internetkonzern
der milliarden in seine produkte
investiert in das betriebssystem die
suchmaschine den navigationsdienst usw
und sie aber an geschäftspartner und
kunden verschenkt also dieses kostenlose
element spielt ja bei dem
geschäftsmodell von google auch eine
rolle ist das rechtlichen problem also
oder kommender inzwischen mit den
herkömmlichen maßstäben drüber
zunächst würde ich gerne wert darauf
legen dass es bei allen diesen digitalen
großunternehmen um eine unglaublich
harte form der shareholder value geht
die innovation und die angeblich welt
verbessern dann gesellschaft verbessern
dann
praktiken die durch diese dienste
geschaffen werden sind nur ein
abfallprodukt
eines ganz stark kapitalistischen auf
shareholder value getriebenen er
business models was meinen sie denn
damit konkret es wenn man sollte nicht
denken dass bei diesen unternehmen
irgendjemand darüber nachdenkt wie man
dem nutzer helfen kann wie man dem
nutzer günstigere angebote geben kann
sondern es geht immer und vor allen
anderen fragen darum wie das unternehmen
noch mehr geld verdienen kann das ist in
der sozialen marktwirtschaft
grundsätzlich nicht verboten aber wir
sollten auch nicht so naiv sein zu
glauben dass dort irgendwelche
ingenieure sitzen die dass die
verbesserung der welt im kopf hätten das
kern anliegen dieser ingenieure ist die
steigerung des eigenen aktienkurses und
des eigenen gewinns wie gesagt das ist
zulässig aber es führt eben dazu dass
sich die politik dann auch fragen muss
wie weit wollen wir das in dieser
extremen form zu lassen und ab wann
beginnt eine gewisse verantwortung der
unternehmen für die nutzer für die
bürger für die demokratie
und da sind wir vielleicht ein bisschen
langsam gewesen zu verstehen dass wir da
als politik dass die regierungen dass
die parlamente hier eine aufgabe haben
wie sie mit nachdruck auch einfordern
müssen kommen wir mal zu zweit
dauerbaustelle bei den digital konzern
das wäre facebook in dem sie anfang des
monat die whistleblower in fences augen
gehört welchen eindruck hat sie auf sie
gemacht
und da sie hat genau das bestätigt was
sie mit der frage zuvor eigentlich hören
wollten dass wir nämlich ein stück weit
im bereich der nutzung von daten
den überblick als gesetzgeber zu
verlieren drohen weil die kombination
aus verschiedenen daten eben mit dem
ziel der steigerung des eigenen profits
inzwischen möglichkeiten bietet die wir
so nicht gesetzgeberisch bis heute
gesehen haben und bei deren regelung wir
natürlich auch ein stück weit vorsichtig
vorgehen müssen weil wir mit
berechtigten gründen die innovation im
digitalen umfeld nicht zerstören wollen
aber vieles von dem deswegen bei mir der
punkt vorher so wichtig was wir bei der
kombination von daten bisher gesehen
haben ist eben nicht passiert um
menschen besser zu informieren um bürger
mehr informationen zu geben sondern wie
frauen bestätigt hat mit einem schönen
beispiel 80 prozent aller
falschinformationen über cobit landen am
ende bei vier prozent der nutzer und es
bedeutet dass es da eben ein
unglaubliches missverhältnis gibt und
dass das was wir als blasenbildung immer
beschreiben so unglaublich stark ist
dass diese blasen nicht wie luftballone
wirken sondern wie mit keine blasen in
die mit hochdruck eine art von meinung
hineingepresst wird so dass der einzelne
oder die einst mäßig möglicherweise in
diesem umfeld auch gar nicht mehr frei
bewegen kann wenn der druck einfach zu
groß wird
der vorwurf dieser müsse bloggerin
versorgen ist jetzt ziemlich deutlich
facebook weiß welche auswirkungen das
soziale netzwerk insbesondere auf
jüngere menschen hatte welche negativen
auswirkungen es auch hat und trotzdem
nichts und zwar weil die
geschäftsinteressen vorgehen kann man da
als gesetzgeber eigentlich so viel
machen oder sind das nicht nur die
gesetzmäßigkeiten des marktes nein also
in der sozialen marktwirtschaft gilt
dass der markt auch einen rahmen braucht
und unternehmen indes die in diesem
rahmen diesen markt nutzen dürfen und
hier ist es natürlich nun so dass wir
mit den informationen die wir schon
hatten und in neuen informationen die
auch von fragen hinzu gegeben wurden nun
besser wissen wie wir diesen rahmen
abstecken können und welche probleme
auch die unternehmen haben wenn es
keinen rahmen gibt denn die facebook hat
ja für die amerikanische
präsidentschaftswahl deshalb frau uns ja
schon ausgeführt versucht die echo
kammern in denen rechtsradikale und
nationalistische
nachrichten und botschaften
stark werden können das ist das summen
des aufnahmen dieser echo kann man vor
der amerikanischen x ungefähr drei
monate vor der wahl reduziert und damit
hat aber die firma natürlich in die
meinungsfreiheit seiner nutzerinnen und
nutzer eingegriffen und dafür gibt es
keine rechtliche grundlage
und insofern tun sich natürlich
unternehmen nicht nur leicht sozusagen
diese diese echo kann man zu bewältigen
und zu gestalten aber richtig ist dass
diese echo kann man zuvor und
wahrscheinlich auch in allen anderen
ländern der welt die nicht einen
besonders ausgeprägten politischen
sensibilität bereich haben für diese art
von themen in all diesen bereichen
macht facebook genauso weiter wie bisher
das nämlich negative nachrichten je
negativer so sind umso stärker am ende
in der echo kammer wirken und deswegen
war der einstieg den sie in dieses
gespräch die welt haben sie machen ja
eigentlich nur ihre arbeit im stück weit
exemplarisch wenn ich in einem solchen
gespräch sage wir müssen all diese
firmen zerschlagen und kaputt machen ist
der output deutlich höher als wenn ich
einfach sage ich gebe meine arbeit nach
und es ist ein stück weg eben auch diese
schieflage die die sozialen medien in
den vergangenen jahren in allen
westlichen gesellschaften mit verursacht
haben das eben normale nachrichten nicht
mehr zählen sondern nur noch
übermäßig zugespitzte aussagen und es
tut keiner demokratie gut und deswegen
geht es dann nicht nur bei der frage der
meinungsfreiheit um viel sondern
natürlich auch in allen anderen fragen
in denen in denen solche digitalen echo
kammern für die moderne gesellschaft
eine rolle spielen und eben auch in den
bereichen wo sie den markt ein stück
welt organisieren
jetzt kommen wir mal zu ihren plänen
also wir haben hier jetzt die künftigen
regulierung die im raum stehen also
einmal den titel markets act und den
digital services act den also beide
projekte hat die kommission
vorgelegt hat ihre pläne da vorgelegt im
vergangenen dezember ist jetzt fast ein
jahr her
jetzt gab es erstmals eine einigung auf
ebene aber ich gehöre sozusagen im
parlament sind sie sich noch nicht so
einig wie ist der stand da und was sind
die knackpunkte
also wir sind uns im europäischen
parlament eigentlich von anfang an
grundsätzlich einig gewesen wir haben
2014 bereits die europäische kommission
aufgefordert alle möglichkeiten des
wettbewerbsrechts auch die aufspaltung
von unternehmen zu nutzen um die
prinzipien der sozialen marktwirtschaft
wieder
ins leben zurück zu bringen im digitalen
umfeld
und wir haben den vorschlag der
europäischen kommission der in der tat
im dezember in der gobi zeit kam nun
jedenfalls weitgehend fertig verhandelt
am montag den 22 werden wir darüber
abstimmen
und insofern kann ich ihnen sagen dass
wir auf einem sehr guten weg sind wir
sind uns grundsätzlich einig dass es
eingesetzt werden muss bis dem dem
parlament wieder die zuständigkeit dafür
gibt was in digitalen umfeld erlaubt ist
und was nicht insbesondere im hinblick
auf die ganz ganz großen unternehmen und
diese ganz ganz großen unternehmen es
geht jetzt zunächst mal für den bitstrom
markets act haben eben im digitalen
umfeld wegen der bedingungen die wir
einleiten diskutiert haben
derart große hebelwirkungen dass sie von
einem markt in einen anderen ihre
marktmacht übertragen können und diese
übertragungs macht führt eben dazu weil
die märkte sich auch so unglaublich
schnell entwickeln im digitalen
zeitalter
die führt dazu dass diese unternehmen
viel schneller wachsen als normale
unternehmen nehmen wir einen
automobilkonzern
in der automobilkonzern kann eben nur
insoweit wachsen wie menschen auf der
welt neue autos kaufen entweder
gebrauchtwagen oder neuwagen aber die
entwicklung da ist eben nicht so dass
sich in china in den letzten 30 jahren
alle menschen zwei neue autos gekauft
hätten sondern die haben halt vielleicht
in den ersten zehn jahren der der
angesprochenen dekade jeweils zu zehn
prozent ein neues auto gekauft in der
zweiten vielleicht haben sie sich dann
30 prozent neues auto gekauft und in der
letzten dekade dann 100 auch noch ein
gebrauchtwagen die wachstumseffekte sind
eben sehr viel begrenzter
weil ich zu digitalen r
wachstumseffekten und diese
wachstumseffekte im digitalen umfeld
führen dazu dass diese möglichkeiten für
die gatekeeper im vergleich zur
klassischen industrie ungemein größer
sind und deswegen brauchen wir dafür
auch andere maßnahme die wollen wir mit
dem diebstahl markt schaffen und dafür
haben wir das instrumentarium des
europäischen wettbewerbsrechts auf der
einen seite wir haben aber eben auch und
das ist eben das neu beim diebstahl
markets act den regulierungsrahmen den
wir so gestalten wollen dass wir
innovation zu lassen aber die prinzipien
der sozialen marktwirtschaft eben
endlich wieder stärker in den
mittelpunkt stellen und damit eben einen
rahmen vorgehen der von der europäischen
kommission hin kontrolliert wird und wie
soll das konkret funktionieren also
insbesondere der letzte punkt der soll
so funktionieren dass wir zunächst
einmal einen rahmen schaffen in dem
festgelegt wird welche unternehmen von
dieser sonderregeln für digitale
großunternehmen betroffen sind es sollen
alle unternehmen seien die mehr als 80
milliarden
markt kapitalisierung aufweisen oder
mehr als acht milliarden am jährlichen
umsatz generieren und die eben eine
dominante position haben das sind
insbesondere die amerikanischen
großunternehmen aber darunter fallen
auch einige europäische unternehmen und
es wird nun an der europäischen
kommission wenn das gesetz verabschiedet
ist daran liegen die unternehmen im
einzelnen ins gebet zu nehmen und im
einzelnen auszuweisen welches
unternehmen als gatekeeper im sinne des
deutschen markt anzusehen ist danach hat
das jeweilige unternehmen in einem
dialog regulator dialogue wie es so
schön heißt mit der europäischen
kommission darzulegen wie es die
prinzipien der sogenannten gebote in
artikel 5 und der verbot den artikel 6
anwendet und lebt und aus dieser analyse
gibt die europäische kommission dann
gewissermaßen eine compliance erklärung
ab um diese compliance muss über das
gesamte geschäftsgebaren des
unternehmens dann immer wieder überprüft
da nur das unternehmen muss nachweisen
dass es sich daran hält wenn nicht die
kommission verschiedene maßnahmen der
strukturellen entflechtung aber auch der
verhaltens mäßigen
einordnung oder anordnung bestimmte
entscheidungen vorsehen und damit sehr
sehr tiefgreifende entscheidungen in
solchen unternehmen vornehmen das heißt
man wartet jetzt nicht mehr bis das kind
in den brunnen gefallen ist und schon
sozusagen alle wettbewerber
ausgeschaltet oder zumindest jedenfalls
über jahre hinweg schlechter behandelt
sondern man er hat sozusagen
grundmisstrauen ja und bittet dann die
unternehmen zum rapport muss mir das so
vorstellen genau es gibt nicht unbedingt
ein grundmisstrauen aber es gibt einen
grund ansatz der eben vorsieht dass die
größten unternehmen im digitalen umfeld
sofern sie viele core platform services
also suchmaschinen e mail services cloud
service anbieten einer besonderen
beobachtung unterliegen und diese
beobachtung dazu führt dass diese
unternehmen selber darlegen müssen dass
sie sich wettbewerbs rechtlich
einwandfrei verhalten und nicht mehr wie
bisher die kommission jahre lang
hinterherlaufen muss um zu beweisen dass
diese unternehmen das wettbewerbsrecht
verletzt haben
sagen sie wie kooperativ sind denn
inzwischen eigentlich die internet
giganten google facebook amazon und co
also hat sich da was getan in den
vergangenen jahren wie würden sie das
miteinander beschreiben
ich würde es mitarbeiter das miteinander
beschreibung in form einer konstruktiven
entwicklung die allerdings seitens der
unternehmen natürlich nach wie vor vom
grundgedanken des shareholder values
geprägt wird nur das was absolut
verboten wird ist am ende auch in einer
geschäftspraxis dieser unternehmen
akzeptiert und respektiert alle
möglichkeiten diese regeln zu umgehen
werden genutzt und diese
umgehungsmöglichkeiten sind enorm weil
wir natürlich die im einzelnen wirkenden
algorithmen und ihre prozesse nach wie
vor nicht in dem maße über ihren wie
notwendig wäre um ein einfaches urteil
zu fällen daran wird sich auch
wahrscheinlich wenig ändern daran wird
sich wenig ändern weil wir natürlich so
schnell nicht die fachleute in die
europäische kommission bekommen die wir
haben wollen insofern ist frau augen mit
ihrem auftreten und das ist wirklich als
mutig zu bezeichnen ein positives
beispiel dafür wie es uns gelingen kann
eben auch insider informationen eher
stärker zu nutzen
und dabei aber auch das verständnis für
den innovativen teil dieser unternehmen
nicht zu verlieren denn wie gesagt es
geht hier nicht um feindschaft oder
ignoranz sondern es geht darum die
algorithmischen techniken zu verstehen
und sicher zu stellen dass die
prinzipien des wirtschaftens in der
europäischen union die von dem
grundgedanken der sozialen
marktwirtschaft geprägt sind eben 100
oder zumindest 90 auch im digitalen
umfeld sicher zu stellen das ist unser
ziel und dem werden wir uns mit dem
bildschirm am definitiv sagen wie stark
mischen sich denn eigentlich die
unternehmen jetzt auch schon in diesen
gesetzgebungsprozess ein weekend sehr
auch von der von der datenschutz grund
verordnung das war ja auch ein großer
kampf im vorfeld viel lobby arbeit wie
nehmen sie das jetzt hier war also der
große erfolg des parlaments bestand
natürlich darin 2014 gewissermaßen an
allen lobby betreuern und
unternehmensmitarbeitern vorbei diese
forderung schon mal mit mehrheit im
parlament platziert zu haben und mein
eindruck ist dass es nur sehr wenig
möglichkeiten gab innerhalb der
beratungen zum vitter markets act
unternehmerischen einfluss zu nehmen
natürlich gibt es bestimmte anliegen die
bekannt sind die kann man aber auch mit
der lektüre des gesetzgebungsvorhaben
sofort verstehen beispielsweise ist dort
ein verbot der selbstprivilegierung
eigener dienste vorgesehen jeder
versteht was damit gemeint ist da
brauchts keine lobbyisten um zu erklären
dass das bestimmten unternehmen weh tut
ich glaube das wissen die unternehmen
auch ich glaube aber auch dass diese
unternehmen natürlich über
technologische möglichkeiten verfügen
diese rechtlichen vorgaben am ende ein
stück weit zu umgehen zu versuchen und
deswegen wird es eine aufgabe für die
europäische kommission werden so gut wie
möglich diese entwicklung zu verfolgen
und sicherzustellen dass der geist des
gesetzes am ende auch angewendet
also wie geht es jetzt weiter wir haben
den
vorschlag der eu kommission wir haben
jetzt die gemeinsame position der eu
mitgliedstaaten jetzt werden sie bald
ihre vorschläge präsentieren und dann
geht es ja in den trilog den berühmten
ganz genau aber die vorschläge des rates
also der vertretung aller
mitgliedstaaten der europäischen union
des europäischen parlaments sind nicht
weit auseinander da gibt es einige
kleinere details über die wir dann
sprechen müssen und die wird in
übereinstimmung bringen müssen richtig
ist dass die mitgliedstaaten gerne etwas
mehr
zuständigkeit hätten noch für ihre
eigenen wettbewerbsbehörden das
europäische parlament und die
europäische kommission sehen
mehrheitlich die aufgabe darin die
vereinheitlichung des regelwerks
sicherzustellen und deswegen die
durchsetzung dieser verfahren die mir
gebiete markt ermöglicht werden auf
europäischer ebene zu führen
darüber wird man sicherlich sprechen
müssen es gibt einige
diskussionen über die frage wie hart er
die regeln diese gebote und verbote für
die einem unternehmen werden sollen da
ist der rat sicherlich etwas weicher und
innovationsorientierte noch als das
europäische parlament das auch auf der
auf basis der erfahrung der
vergangenheit hier etwas härter
zuschlagen will aber unterm strich
wollen wir am ende das gleiche wir
wollen einen regulator eine europäische
behörde die tatsächlich auf augenhöhe
mit diesen unternehmen verhandelt und
die europäischen regeln eins zu eins
umsetzt
ich habe ich danke für das gespräch
vielen dank im voraus
so jetzt verlassen wir das thema digital
konzerne und kommen zurück dazu die
niederungen der großkanzleien und dem
bgh das werden sie bestimmt nicht geben
so der bgh hat entschieden dass ein noch
sehr junger richter in frankfurt am main
nicht in einem prozess entscheiden darf
weil er befangen ist oder befangen sein
könnte das reicht ja bekanntlich aus in
den so genannten lkw kartellverfahren
dabei geht es um schadensersatz klagen
gegen das lkw kartell naheliegenderweise
da hatte die eu-kommission schon im juli
2016 vorgestellt das sich diverse
lkw-hersteller also preisabsprachen
getroffen hatten und jetzt werden die
natürlich landesweit bei den gerichten
verklagt unter anderem auch am
landgericht frankfurt am main da gibt es
wohl von 28 hessischen städten
schadensersatzklagen also die wollen
geld zurück kartell schadensersatz und
sagen halt ja ihr habt uns hier zu viel
geld abgeknöpft weil ihr die preise
abgesprochen haben liebe lkw-hersteller
das ist in der sache auch gar nicht so
relevant aber ich muss ein bisschen
erzählen damit klar wird wo ihr das
etwas grundlegendes problem wird denn
der beisitzende richter in der
zuständigen kammer am frankfurter
landgericht hat dann zu verfahrensbeginn
mitgeteilt dass er als referendar und
wissenschaftlicher mitarbeiter
noch im jahr ich glaube zwei 19 und
sogar 220 in der großkanzlei hengeler
mueller gearbeitet hat so weit so und
immerhin redlich das können wir hier
auch würdigen also ich finde eine
selbstverständlichkeit ja aber genau ja
eigentlich ist es eine
selbstverständlichkeit aber hinaus du
hast recht man kann ja auch mal
friedliches verhalten positiv
hervorheben und entsprechend
wertschätzen nun hat sich beim gemälde
und hat gesagt leute ich weiß hier nicht
kann ich das machen denn ich habe bei
hengeler relativ viel engeren kurven
sachen gemacht wie gesagt ja und das ist
ja total surprising weil natürlich ganz
viele großkanzleien eingebunden sind in
diese lkw kartellverfahren die haben
natürlich also alle lkw hersteller die
da eben jetzt beklagte sind und
schadensersatz zahlen sollen haben
natürlich alle in den allermeisten
fällen sehr große kanzlei beauftragt und
die wiederum beauftragen natürlich
armeen von wissenschaftlichen
mitarbeitern und das sales und so weiter
da recherche zu machen und verteidigungs
strategie auszuarbeiten also händler hat
hier glaube ich ma n vertreten und
daraufhin als der richter das angezeigt
hat haben dann zwei andere beteiligte in
diesen verfahren befangenheitsanträge
gestellt ich glaube eines davon war
daimler und haben gesagt leute so geht
das aber nicht dieser richter ist dann
befangen vom landgericht und vorm olg
waren sie damit noch erfolglos die haben
so ein bisschen gesagt naja ganz ehrlich
leute der typ war der referendar und ein
bisschen bis mit hat da wohl jetzt keine
persönlichen beziehungen zum management
von ma n geknüpft oder so das reicht uns
nicht der kartellsenat am bgh sieht es
jetzt anders und sagt jo das reicht uns
sehr wohl da liegt ein böser schein der
fehlenden unabhängigkeit vor achtung
jura nord das ist ein fall der
sogenannten atypischen um fassung also
nämlich dann wenn richter nicht als
richter mit einem verfahren schon mal
irgendwann befasst waren also zum
beispiel du hast mal irgendwie in der
anderen kammer prozesskostenhilfe
verfahren gemacht oder ein eilverfahren
dass sich mit demselben streitgegenstand
befasst hat oder so als richter sondern
wenn du eben in anderer funktion bereits
mit einer sache befasst war und da sagt
der bgh jetzt dass sie ist ein so
ähnlicher fall das geht nicht also es
geht zwar nicht um sozusagen dasselbe
verfahren also es war jetzt nicht so
dass er das in dem verfahren dass jetzt
vor dem landgericht frankfurt anfängt
der referendar irgendwie eine
verteidigungsstrategie damals wn
ausgearbeitet hatte aber der bgh sagt
eben und deshalb ist es auch relevant
das ist das lkw kartellverfahren ist das
sind halt sehr leicht gemacht hat die
sachverhalte die alle daraus resultieren
dass die eu-kommission bindend
festgestellt hat er war teilnehmer am
lkw kartell das sich eigentlich zwischen
diesen ganzen prozessen in der sache
total wenig tut und obwohl dann der
streitgegenstand nicht genau derselbe
ist stimmt es in den kernpunkten soweit
überein dass die gesagt haben das geht
irgendwie gar nicht es könnte halt schon
sein dass er da bestimmte kenntnisse
erlangt hat auch wenn ein anfangs nur
referendar oder wismut war von
bestimmten verteidigungsstrategien oder
auch bedeutsam sachverhalts details die
man vielleicht im hintergrund weiß aber
im verfahren aus bestimmten gründen
nicht verträgt dass das auf jeden fall
relevant sein und dieses argument der
wagen war referendar oder wissen mit
überzeugten bghz nicht die sagen der hat
arbeit mehr gemacht als da irgendwie in
der ausbildungsordnung drinsteht oder
gesetzlich geboten wäre denn der hätte
in dem also hat er ja auch selber gesagt
er hat den gesamtkomplex lkw kartell
aufgearbeitet daneben in dem damals für
händler für m a m und das eben um den
beklagten unternehmen eine
schlagkräftige rechne reinigung zu
ermöglichen da sagt der bgh das sieht
alles nicht gut aus und vor allem
wichtiger punkt das war erst ganz kurz
her also wenn das jetzt zehn jahre her
gewesen wäre geschenkt wahrscheinlich
aber das lag hat diese diese letztmalige
tätigkeit für händler lag zum zeitpunkt
des prozesses nicht mal ein jahr zurück
und da sagt der bgh hat ist auch
zeitlich noch zu nah dran also ich muss
auch sagen ich weiß auch gar nicht wie
genau wie man auf ein anderes ergebnis
kommen kann weil also ich finds schon
auch dass man jetzt befangenheitsanträge
nicht ausufern lassen sollte natürlich
sollte das sollte die befangenheit schon
etwas sein was eigentlich eher eine
ausnahme rolle spielt weil sonst kommst
du auch wirklich in teufels küche
aber ich also in so einer konstellation
hätte ich das auch
selbstverständlich gefunden dass man ihm
sagt also hier jetzt eben auch nicht
weil es eher auch vor allen dingen um
den bösen schein haid gegner und nicht
darüber ob der jetzt tatsächlich immer
quasi die in monster berieselt wurde mit
allen
argumenten genießen und vor allen dingen
auch mit argumenten die ausschließlich
zulasten der beteiligten dann irgendwie
gewogen werden also na ja also
jedenfalls da es ist natürlich trotzdem
in der summe irgendwie eine krasse
entscheidung weil das betrifft ja nicht
nur das lkw kartellverfahren sondern
natürlich naheliegenderweise auch so was
wie die diesel verfahren also die abgas
skandal verfahren auch da sind ja
überall an allen ecken und enden
großkanzleien beteiligt und natürlich
sind da an allen ecken und enden
referendare und wismut beteiligt das
heißt ich könnte mir schon vorstellen
dass da jetzt vielleicht in einigen
großkanzleien schon leute sitzen die mal
die lebensläufe der rechte der
beteiligten sicheren checken und gucken
wo wart ihr denn die letzten zwei drei
jahren obwohl richter geworden seid ihr
lieben genau aber die konzert ist wird
er auch noch ein paar richter geben die
ihm nicht
bei einer großkanzlei gearbeitet haben
man versuche es werd ich würde mir
zumindest mal angucken in den verfahren
ja dass wir also liegen habe könnte
jetzt natürlich alle gerne machen und
ich wie gesagt da habe ich auch größtes
verständnis wenn es dann tatsächlich so
ist ich glaube dass es sich dann in der
er tatsächlich in der realität dann doch
eher in grenzen hält die auswirkung und
merkwürdig aber auch das ist bis zum bgh
laufen musste ja und merkwürdig dass man
davon zum ersten mal hört für mich also
das hätte ich mir jetzt geht das hätte
schon häufiger auf java auch gesagt ist
es schon getreten ist es schon auch eine
spezielle konstellation wenn es nicht
wie gesagt ich glaube so selten es ist
vermutlich gar nicht nein ich meine
menschen mit qualifikation zum richter
amt sind ja nun mal auch in der regel
relativ gute juristinnen und juristen
nur das heißt sie haben gute noten viele
von denen waren mit sicherheit mal
zumindest in ein massage in der
großkanzlei also ganz so
unwahrscheinlich finde ich das ja aber
ist er wirklich nicht nur jetzt um ihn
nicht nur darum dass der nur in einer
großkanzlei warne und sich dann mit ganz
anderen mit patentrecht oder so
beschäftigt hätte sondern er war ja auch
tatsächlich am lkw kartell beschäftigt
zwar für ein anderes unternehmen aber
das war schon einfach ein absolut
vergleichbare sachverhalte und diese
konnte ist ein skandal ja die sind schon
die sind nicht ganz so vergleichbar wie
sie lkw kartell na klar aber das könnte
man zumindest mal versuchen ich könnte
mir schon vorstellen dass es versucht
wirklich ja und da hätte ich kein
problem ich auch nicht so damit sind wir
durch
[Musik]
dann sind wir jetzt schon bei den
nachträgen
horst ersten schönen nach es geht
einfach nur wieder an britney spears
hatten wir schon lange rauf und runter
besprochen vor einigen wochen jetzt
können wir vollzug melden also sie hat
ihr erstes wochenende in freiheit ja
nach 13 jahren vormundschaft had been
ist ihre freiheit zurück so heißt es
rauf und runter in den medien ist ein
schönes restaurant gegangen das schönste
restaurant das ich jemals gesehen hat
hat ihr erstes glas champagner getrunken
und dafür ganz viele likes bekommen ja
und so ist es wir hatten ja darüber
gesprochen als der vormund also der
vater abgesetzt wurde als vormund der
sängerin und eine ersatz person bestimmt
wurde das war ende september
und jetzt wurde eben die vormundschaft
generell beendet dann sagen wir
herzlichen glückwunsch und hoffentlich
hält sich die feierei auch in grenzen
ich glaube heute feiert er jetzt schon
länger nach dem was man so den sozialen
medien herren konnte das also wird sich
dann wohl auch sein irgendwann wieder
runter regeln aber ich werde auch nicht
so moralinsauer hier
feiern verbieten aber denkt
man wirklich abstürze so aber dann haben
wir noch einen anderen wesentlich
erfreulichere nachtrag da musst du jetzt
dran genau und wir wissen schon gar
nicht ob wir das immer als nachtrag
behandeln sollen weil eigentlich sind
dass sie einmal alles neue kissen da was
ist natürlich immer ein nachtrag zur
ewigen eskalation zwischen der eu und
polen da gibt es schon wieder hässliche
neuigkeiten und zwar hat der europäische
gerichtshof am gestrigen dienstag wir
zeichnen auf am mittwoch erneut
festgestellt dass rechtsvorschriften im
polnischen justizsystem
europarechtswidrig sind diesmal geht es
konkret um die abordnung von richtern
und deshalb ist das ein bisschen bekannt
und durchaus erwähnenswert diesmal
betrifft die entscheidung den
justizminister höchstselbst denn der
eugh hat festgestellt dass der
justizminister viel zu viel macht hat
als dass das noch irgendwie rechtsstaat
worum geht's der justizminister kann in
polen nach derzeit geltendem recht eben
nach der justizreform richterinnen und
richter an ein strafgericht höherer
ordnung abordnen zwar formal die
abordnung funktioniert nur mit der
zustimmung der richterinnen und richter
allerdings kann der justizminister das
ohne begründung und ohne im voraus klare
kriterien ansagen also es gibt überhaupt
keine kriterien die irgendwie offiziell
bekannt werden dafür und der
justizminister kann diese abordnung auch
jederzeit wieder beenden wiederum nach
nicht bekannten kriterien und das auch
sogar ohne zustimmung der richterin oder
des sohnes also eine unglaubliche
machtfülle ja und hinzu kommt noch dass
die entscheidung über diese abordnung
vor allem über auch die beendigung der
abordnung wo es eben nicht meine
zustimmung braucht keinerlei
gerichtliche kontrolle unterliegt das
sollten die richterinnen und richter
können dagegen nichts tun so und das war
natürlich der bgh jetzt nicht so witzig
und was ist jetzt in meinem ort herum
gekommen
surprise der liga sagt das ist nicht nur
nicht so witzig sondern das ist
unvereinbar mit dem erfordernis der
richterlichen unabhängigkeit und auch
mit der unschuldsvermutung
das fand ich ganz spannend dass nochmals
kleiner schlenker die unschuldsvermutung
setzt nämlich auch voraus dass der
richter unparteiisch und
unvoreingenommen ist wenn er die
strafrechtliche verantwortlichkeit des
angeklagten trifft also das kann man
vielleicht auch mal im kopf behalten
auch unter den prüfungs kontext
sozusagen sehr spannend aber lange rede
kurzer sinn der ogh sieht die sehr
deutliche gefahr dass die regelungen zur
abordnung von richtern zur politischen
kontrolle eingesetzt werden wenn sie zur
politischen kontrolle der richterinnen
und richter und damit auch das inhalts
justizieller entscheidungen also und
selbst wenn man die abordnung nur mit
zustimmung vornehmen kann sagt der bh
geht es irgendwie gar nicht und es ist
trotzdem denkbar dass diese abgeordneten
richterinnen und richter natürlich
beeinflusst werden empfohlen und es
müsste zumindest bekannte also im voraus
bekannte und transparente kriterien
geben für so eine abordnung für das ende
der abordnung und diese abordnung kann
nicht beendet werden ohne dass man
dagegen als richterin oder richter
werden kann denn du wirst ja dann quasi
wieder runtergestuft auf ein gericht
weiter unten das wird vermutlich auch
mit mit einer solche änderungen
einhergehen und das hat halt eine
auswirkung wie ein disziplinarverfahren
im prinzip aber das ist jetzt so ein
weiterer baustein das heißt in dem
zusammenhang gibt es jetzt keine weitere
millionen
forderungen oder also noch was die gibt
es die gibt es jetzt noch nicht also ich
nehme schon anders wenn das nicht in
absehbarer zeit geändert wird irgendwie
es dann ein neues verfahren geben könnte
in dem der ogh wieder sagt und das ist
jetzt die nächste million oder halbe
million an strafe die der pro tag fällig
wird was aber noch ein hinweis wertig
verwehrt ist verdichten das hat der ogh
extra noch erwähnt obwohl das von dem
vorlegenden gericht aus warschau
eigentlich gar nicht angefragt worden
war er hat noch den schlenker gemacht
und gesagt es geht übrigens auch gar
nicht dass der justizminister
gleichzeitig auch der
generalstaatsanwalt des staates also der
höchster ankläger und das war eigentlich
hier gar nicht gefragt da hat er ja
explizit festgestellt mit dem begriff
der macht das also in einem bestimmten
strafverfahren sowohl über den
staatsanwalt als auch über eine
abgeordnete richterin zum beispiel der
justizminister die macht hat und sagen
natürlich leute bei aller liebe das ist
echt komplett und denkbar wie gesagt das
geht jetzt direkt gegen den gegen den
justizminister helms 11 das ist ja
bekanntlich ein relativ konservativer
hardliner mal freundlich ausgedrückt in
europa skeptiker wir haben das alles
relativ
stark aufgedröselt in folge 184 von 311
da haben wir auch die
gesamtzusammenhänge noch mal so ein
bisschen dargestellt die beiden klagen
von polen und ungarn gegen den geplanten
rechtsstaats mechanismus und so weiter
die eu hält jetzt zahlungen zurück auf
die polen dringend wartet weil eben
polen diese strafzahlungen die es jetzt
schon aus zwei verfahren schulden würde
braunen haaren 1,5 millionen nicht
leistet und die spirale dreht sich immer
schneller und im prinzip ist kein ausweg
in sicht das ist bitter aber so ist es
und deswegen kommen wir jetzt ganz
schnell weil es so bitter war zu den
gerechten unter der woche
du fängst an die wp genau ich fange an
mit einem urteil das klingt erstmal ein
bisschen lustig ehrlich gesagt wenn man
sich dass zwei sekunden überlegt es ist
überhaupt nicht mehr lustig aber umso
gerechter ist es und zwar ist vor dem
oberlandesgericht in karlsruhe 1 doch
können dann nachbar zur zahlung von
44.000 euro umzugskosten verurteilt
wurden fair enough kann man da nur sagen
also es wirklich eine alptraum wenn man
diese pressemitteilung ist da ist eine
familie in das haus neben diesen
menschen starb er ist heute über 60 im
jahr 2014 eingezogen und dieser typ hat
sofort damit begonnen die familie zu
schikanieren und schikanieren ist jetzt
nicht nur so ein bisschen lustig
zigarren irrt nerviger nachbar sondern
er hat angefangen die vom eigenen
fenster aus permanent zu beobachten dann
hat er nachts an die hauswand der
familie geklopft und hat dann auch uns
hat sich immer weiter gesteigert und
irgendwann hat er sie derbe beleidigt
schreibt das olg ohne weitere ich sag
mal spezifizierungen im jahr 2017 hat es
sogar konkrete todesdrohungen gegeben
also im april hat er den beiden
irgendwie angebot er würde jetzt eine
pistole aus seinem haus holen und im
juli ist es dann völlig eskaliert 17 da
ist er dem ehemann abends mit einem
erhobenen ball hinterhergelaufen gottes
und als erwartete horror es ist ein raum
der stille nacht oh du kannst ein haus
praktisch nicht mehr verlassen weil da
so ein irrer nebenan wohnt und der
ehemann konnte dann zwar fliehen aber
dann hat er sich halt in seinem
wutanfall den beiden autos zugewandt und
hat dann die beiden wagen total
zerschlagen nachdem weil ja und das war
den dann erstaunlicherweise irgendwann
zu viel und die familie hat sich
entschlossen unterziehen dann sind sie
erst in der mietwohnung gezogen haben
sich dann neues haus gekauft und haben
dann relativ clevere idee finde ich
eigentlich die umzugskosten und die
nebenkosten für das neue haus also
bedeutet grunderwerbsteuer die note aaa
ist deswegen bei die sindlinger
eingefordert genau deswegen sind wir bei
den 40.000 euro ja genau die wollten
noch mehr haben die wollten insgesamt
sogar 113000 euro haben nämlich und das
ist ein bisschen lustig den minderwert
vor allem des alten hauses das ja jetzt
verkauft hat wenn sie nämlich den
käufern gesagt haben wer da nebenan
wohnt und dann hat das haus natürlich
weniger ein kann man irgendwie
nachvollziehen plus die maklercourtage
frauen dann hat dann haben sie erstmal
verloren in der ersten instanz beim lg
mannheim die haben haben sie gar nichts
bekommen das olg karlsruhe sagt aber
jetzt
44.000 von den 113 1000 die ihr wolltet
kriegt ihr und zwar die umzugskosten und
die nebenkosten für das neue haus also
notarkosten und grunderwerbsteuern muss
man wahrscheinlich damit rechnen dass er
die nicht zahlen kann aber es geht auch
ums prinzip oder meist nicht absolut und
ich kenne die lebensumstände dieses
mannes nicht wer weiß vielleicht hat er
ja auch furchtbar viel geld aber ich
möchte doch noch mal kurz die besucher
hier anmerken wie das olg karlsruhe das
begrünte und zwar hat das uniqa zurück
sagt der nachbar hat sich strafbar
gemacht erstens wegen bedrohung nach
links und zweitens wegen nachstellung
also das was man im volksmund stalking
nennt denn das sind ja eben nicht nur
die fälle die man so im kopf hat was
weiß ich der verrückt der ex denen man
nicht mehr los wird oder irgend so ein
freak der dann im diffusen licht in der
bushaltestelle vor dem haus steht und
ein beobachtet und einem unheimlichen
whatsapp nachrichten schickt sondern
auch der nachbar kann eben ein stalker
seine diesem sinne also einem nach
stellen heißt es im stgb denn es geht ja
eigentlich darum dass das leute sind die
an das leben zur hölle machen so und das
ist dann jetzt 38 absatz 1 nummer vier
wer einer anderen person in einer weise
und nach stellt die geeignet ist deren
lebensgestaltung nicht unerheblich zu
beeinträchtigen in diesem fall indem er
wiederholt diese person eben bedroht das
kann man glaube ich sagen dass dieser
mensch das getan hat also long story
short strafbar wegen bedrohung und wegen
nachstellung und damit sind wir beim
schutz gesetzen im sinne von § 823
absatz 2 bürgerliches gesetzbuch ja und
dann sorgt das ohr geht dann sind
schäden ersatzfähig die vom schutzzweck
der strafnorm erfasst sind wir schon auf
den 8 23 2 prüfen musste erinnert sich
das irgendwie total gruselig diesen
schutzzweck der strafnorm irgendwie sich
zu überlegen diesen hässlichen
schutzzweck zusammenhang nennt man das
hier hat der senat gesagt wir sehen den
schutzzweck zusammenhang für die kosten
die die familie zur wiederherstellung
ihres persönlichen sicherheitsgefühls
aufwenden musste interessanter ansatz
jedenfalls kommen dabei aus sicht des
oeg umzugs und die kosten des kaufs des
neuen hauses raus die wertminderung am
alten haus weil eben der nachbarn
nebenan wohnt und die maklerprovision
haben sie da nicht gesehen das seien
bloße vermögens folgeschäden die
außerhalb des experten wie hoch waren
eigentlich der abschlag für den bösen
nachbarn also wie weit muss man darunter
einer nicht erkennbar da hält sich in
das lg oder rein schauen müssen das habe
ich geschafft gestern aber das wir so
wirst du man also jetzt ja aber ich
nehme an das würde nicht so wenig
gewesen sein ich meine die wollten
113.000 44.000 bekommen also da wird
schon ein großer teil der dazwischen die
gewinnsumme wird dieser abschlag gewesen
sein der minderwert wegen des verrückten
stockenden nachbarn ansonsten waren nur
noch die maklerprovision also da bleibt
uns nur freundliche nachbarn zu wünschen
im neuen haus ganz ehrlich schon
ignorante nachbarn finde ich total in
ordnung ist es reicht ja schon wenn sie
nicht völlig verrückt sind und einem das
leben zur hölle machen eigentlich gibt
es ziemlich viele nachbarn mit dem man
gut die nach dem floralen nebeneinander
her leben kann und wenn es hin und
wieder mal ein paar freya gibt dann wäre
das natürlich auch gut
gut aber jetzt kommen wir zu einem noch
viel höheren verfahren und zwar schon
wieder in berlin ja wir haben es schon
angedeutet im intro es geht um zwei
angehörige eines berliner clans und es
geht um einen anwalt ja und hier geht es
wieder um eine immobilie gekauft
und da hätte man sich mal den milieus
schützen schutz vom anfang gewünscht
dass da irgendjemand mal einschreiten
und sagt hier kann man nicht
verkaufsrecht burghaus rechts und so
weiter da hat dann die berliner
community offensichtlich geschlafen weil
es ist so ein bisschen das nora fall der
jetzt auch zügig durch die gazetten
geistert weil es um 1 80 jähriges
ehepaar geht das wirklich völlig hilflos
mit ansehen musste wie ihm das
mehrfamilienhaus also die kapital
unter dem hintern weggezogen wurde jetzt
mal sehr und technisch gesprochen aber
es ist wirklich auch so ein bisschen
in ihrer freien an dem man auch noch
einmal die besonderheiten des
immobilienkaufs erklären kann weil der
ja eigentlich bombensicher sein soll und
man dann immer wieder sieht naja wenn
dann klar mit da mitmischen und
winkeladvokaten wie die bild schreibt
der und berufsbedingt vorauswahl der
bild ungern mal recht geben
ehrlich gesagt
dann wird einem also ganz schwach auf
der brust ich meine keine zeit auch
erstmal wäre die vier herren waren die
an diesem ganzen q nennen wir es mal coo
der zum glück nicht funktioniert hat
beträgt ja und dann sind insbesondere im
fokus zwei brüder aus dem berüchtigten
abou chaker klar
dass werden inzwischen viele leute
kennen weil er hier in berlin auch sehr
bekannt ist und vor allen dingen weil
sich diese clan mitglieder immer mal
wieder in unterschiedlichen
strafverfahren
stellen müssen ein weiteres
gerichtsverfahren hat ein anderes clan
oder der ich glaube das ist sozusagen
der clan-chef
zusammenhang mit bushido dem rapper
bushido hier in die warnow früherer
geschäftspartner und da geht es jetzt um
sehr gewalttätige sehr hässlich
auseinandersetzungen schon seit sehr
vielen prozess noch genauer sind
geschäftspartner und auch befreundet
gewesen haben sich ein schönes
grundstück in kleinmachnow bei berlin
zusammen geleistet da ja das ist
irgendwie auseinandergebrochen und das
beschäftigt jetzt die berliner
gerichte und dass wir war aber an
anderen fall ich sag das jetzt nur um
damit wieder so ein bisschen ein ordnen
können wir diese akkus abou chaker
apotheker kleinen jungs sind
zwar noch an wie gesagt vorbestrafter
kaufmann dabei ein berufs betrüger und
ein jurist ja und was haben wir gemacht
die haben eben dieses mehrfamilienhaus
sich was hier in berlin und wohlstand
oder immer noch steht wie man hofft hat
irgendwie unseren geschätzten wert von
sechs millionen ist also recht
ordentlich und die kam auf eine wirklich
echt ab so die idee die haben halt
geldprobleme gehabt und dann war man auf
der suche danach
einkunftsquelle und da kam diese
immobilienkaufmann auf die ideen er gibt
es doch dieses raus das sind
offensichtlich betrag der eigentümer die
wohl auch gar nicht in berlin die wohn
in hamburg den können wir doch mal den
dass das haus
clown
so heißt es wieder
wir das haus clown ohne dass dies merken
und wir sterben dann dass das haus für
also
millionen euro her und haben einfach
dann monströsen gewinn gemacht weil wir
natürlich nie auf der anderen seite das
ganze ist eher ein betrugsfall der
tatsächlichen kauf
geschlossen worden zwischen diesem
ehepaar den eigentlichen eigentümer
genau dieses arme betagte ehepaar hatte
keine ahnung davon die sitzen da in
hamburg freuen sich über ihren
lebensabend und irgendwann werden sie
von der versicherung darüber informiert
dass ihr haus nicht mehr das ist
übrigens der grund warum die sache
überhaupt aufgeflogen ist weil einem
haus sieht man ja nicht an wem es gehört
ja deswegen ist ja das ganze auch so
abgesichert wenn man kann auch
immobilien übertragungen und
immobilienverkäufer auch nur beim notar
abschließen das wird dann im grundbuch
eingetragen dauert ewigkeiten kostet
wahnsinnig viel geld ja auch an
grundbuch gebühren und hast du nicht
gesehen und so weiter und wird
eigentlich von vorne bis hinten geprüft
aber
offensichtlich waren nicht in diesem
fall nicht in diesem fall entweder waren
sie sehr geschickt
da auch der notar irgendwie blauäugig zu
doof oder vielleicht sogar mit dabei das
ist relativ offen in diesem fall aber
wir haben die das gemacht die haben sich
also dieses haus ausgeguckt und haben
dann eine immobiliengesellschaft
gegründet die den namen dieses
grundstückes hat weshalb das eine rolle
spielt da muss ich leider passen
der vollständigkeit halber und die sind
dann eben einem zum zu einem notar
gegangen der jurist mimte eben den
vertreter dieses ehepaars die von ihrem
schicksal nichts wussten der tauchte
ebenda beim notar auf und schloss dann
mit der gesellschaft diesen kaufvertrag
über schäbige
250.000 euro also das natürlich ein
absurder betrag ist alleine da muss
eigentlich jeder normal denkende mensch
sagen moment mal ein haus in der mitte
von berlin mit mehreren mietwohnungen
drin die alle vermietet sind für 250.000
euro da muss man nicht nur hellhörig
werden dann müssen alle alarmglocken an
geht in der regel richtig ist
offensichtlich hier nicht passiert also
diese umstände der bekundung oder
beurkundungen die es offenbar gegeben
hat sind unklar wer also wir konnten das
jetzt auch nicht mehr recherchieren und
offenbar hat es auch niemand anders
geschafft das zu recherchieren
wir können es uns kaum anders vorstellen
als dass da ein notar mit drin gehangen
haben muss aber das ist eine reine eine
reine vermutung und wir wissen nicht mal
genau wie der sachverhalt nicht
abgespielt werden also man muss dann
eben dazu sagen für alle diejenigen die
sich wundern naja also eigentlich
müssten doch alle persönlich vor dem
notar erscheine also sowohl käufer als
auch verkäufer dann trifft man sich
normalerweise kriegt eine ordentliche
tasse tee oder kaffee und verhandelt
sehr mühselig oder liest der hund genau
der vertrag ist er schon verhandelt dann
wird eben sehr mühselig dieser vertrag
vorgelesen und es müssen die
personalausweise gezeigt werden und die
werden auch ordentlich geprüft und es
wird
eine kopie davon
hergestellt und so weiter und so fort
also das eigentlich ein sehr mühseliger
prozess
und das kann aber auch anders laufen in
diesem fall ist es wohl offensichtlich
so gewesen so haben wir uns das zusammen
das ist wie gesagt nur beim verkauf
tatsächlich der jurist als vertreter des
ehepaars anwesend war und der käufer und
das dann später
genau der vertrag genehmigt wurde
angeblich von diesem betagten ehepaar
aber das war in wahrheit immer noch
nichts von dem allem was da ablief
sondern das sind offensichtlich
laienschauspieler gewesen auch die waren
aber nicht mehr auffindbar april also
alles total dubios aber wir gehen davon
aus dass es so gewesen sein muss das
also erst der anwalt als vertreter quasi
für die verkäufer angeblichen verkäufer
aufgetreten ist und nachher dann
laiendarsteller diesen vertrag genehmigt
haben also das vermutlich sogar zwei
notare beteiligt gewesen sind hat auch
nichts genutzt der kaufvertrag wurde
aufgesetzt und beurkundet also
vermutlich dann auch danach noch
genehmigt und dann ist das ganze seinen
normalen gang gegangen wurde ans
grundbuchamt geschickt und dann ist das
beim grundbuchamt eingetragen worden und
schwupps war dieses arme 80-jährige
ehepaar nicht mehr eigentümer seien ja
so schnell kann es dann nämlich
tatsächlich dann doch gehen oder nicht
dass man weiß die waren natürlich
einigermaßen verdutzt da haben ja
immerhin gott sei dank diesen hinweis
bekommen von der versicherung dass die
gekündigt wurde weil das ein
eigentümerwechsel gegeben hat ja und die
sind dann natürlich auf die barrikaden
gegangen haben alles in bewegung gesetzt
um die das wieder rückgängig zu machen
und das hat ehrlich ist auch das dauert
dann ewigkeiten also es ist man die rede
davon dass sie 140000 euro investieren
mussten um das wieder zurückzudrehen
muss man sich auch mal vorstellen wie
komplex das ganze verfahren dann ja dann
auch ist ja wenn es ein kunststück hatte
ja theoretisch weiterverkauft werden
können das war ja aller voraussicht nach
auch der plan sieht halt in der
zwischenzeit einkassiert worden die sind
bei einer razzia ende 2020 durch zufall
aus ganz an gründen einkassiert worden
genau die wollten ja eigentlich auch
dieses haus weiterverkaufen und wie
gesagt für sieben millionen euro das hat
dann eben nicht mehr funktioniert weil
die eigentümer da alles in bewegung
gesetzt haben und da eingeschritten sind
aber das ganze war jetzt eben ein
strafverfahren was vor dem landgericht
berlin stattgefunden hat wir müssen noch
mal sagen was die vier typen haben sie
denn nicht bekommt genau vorwurf waren
natürlich betrug im besonders schweren
fall allerdings und dann
urkundenfälschung sowie mittelbarer
falschbeurkundung
also urkundenfälschungen lag eben daran
dass die gefälschte ausweise da benutzt
haben und die mittelbarer
falschbeurkundung weil sie dann durch
den
durch das trocken des notars
ist aber ein übertriebener euphemismus
hier
muss ich aber mal schimpfen die
rechtsstaatlich schimpfen so zu sagen ja
das sieht die das berliner gericht aber
ganz anders als das nur ein vorwand
ich wollte er denn sie haben quasi die
mittelbare daran dass sie die notar hier
eingesetzt haben um die
falschbeurkundung
durchzusetzen also wir haben es nicht
konnten das natürlich nicht selber
machen deswegen mittelbar und
tatsächlich du hast insofern wahnsinnig
recht als dass das natürlich noch mal in
besonders beschweren das war ne dass man
hier also auch die das vertrauen in das
grundbuch und in die staatlichen
vorgänger da und die glaubwürdigkeit des
grundbuchs auch erschüttert hat mit
diesem fall das hat die ganze sache noch
mal besonders schwerwiegend gemacht und
da hab ich mal fragen wie überzeugend du
das findest ich finde das ist ein ganz
merkwürdiges strafschärfend grund also
nur dass das landgericht hat so ein
bisschen gesagt na ja also die
ursprünglichen eigentümer ist er um
sechs millionen euro geprellt quasi aber
sie haben eben gesagt nicht nur
vermögensverlust großen ausmaßes sondern
es gehe um ein angriff auf bedeutende
werte des rechtssystems und vertrauen in
ihrer lässigkeit von notaren und
grundbüchern und ich muss sagen ich
finde das schon ein bisschen erstaunlich
ja krasse kriminelle energie sehe ich
auch so aber kann es wirklich jetzt
zulasten der täter gehen dass ihn
entweder schlechten oder selbst
kriminell notar gefunden haben und auf
einen offenbar mal mindestens
desinteressiert das grundbuchamt
getroffen sind das finde ich schon eine
sehr merkwürdige strafe also ich höre
ich sofort in revision gehen ich hab
kann es ja machen
ich fand das jeden fall wieder kein
ehrlich gesagt durchaus überzeugen wenn
er überhaupt nicht
bin überhaupt nicht drüber gestolpert
weil wie gesagt also das grundbuch
kommen ja nicht ohne grund tatsächlich
auch ganz besondere
beweisfunktion funktionen zu ja also und
dass die dann besonders geschützt wird
kann ich mir auch vorstellen
letztendlich muss man ja auch sagen ich
weiß auch gar nicht ob die die strafen
wirklich so wahnsinnig hart sein man
muss ja sagen für die beiden apotheker
jungs waren es vier jahre und zehn
monate
allerdings nach dir ne also da die
werden schon runter gegangen seien weil
die haben sich ja verständlich die haben
gestanden und haben deshalb ein
niedriges strafmass bekommen wäre und
dann dieser immobilien kaufmann der auch
schon vorbestrafter hat sechs jahre und
neun monate bekommen und der
winkeladvokat wie die bild so schön
schreibt bekommt drei jahre und sechs
monate
jaja bestreitet auch wieder alles und
sagt ich habe nur am schreibtisch
gesessen ich wusste nichts von betrug so
also ich finde es na ja es kommt so ein
bisschen darauf an eben auf die auf die
jeweilige vorgeschichte natürlich die
kennen wir jetzt zu wenig aber ich finde
schon auch also fast sieben jahre ist
schon wieder ansagen für den auch wenn
dieser merkwürdige dubiose geschäftsmann
in anführungszeichen wohl der
drahtzieher war und wohl auch den
hauptteil der beute hätte haben wollen
ist das schon jetzt nicht wenig nur
sechs jahre und neun monate ja das
stimmt allerdings aber die bild regt
sich ihm auf dass die schalker jungs
jetzt auf freien fuß erst mal sind nur
weil ja wie gesagt sie auch noch in die
nächste instanz gehen können
und
weil die wohl auch schon lange in u haft
saß und dann sind sie erstmal in audi
gestiegen und dann konnten sie ihre
sachen im lamborghini
nach hause schaffen und so also die bild
hat das alles ziemlich genau
dokumentiert ich finde es auch gut dass
man sich darum die wichtigen dinge
bemüht bei der bild zeitung ich wollte
noch kurz fragen ich habe in der
süddeutschen die hat es auch kurz das
war also keine sachen der boulevard den
wir hier mal wieder besprechen sondern
das ist ja wirklich eine irre geschichte
die auch echt erzählenswert ist weil ich
finde es zeigt doch auch sehr wie sich
das was man sich so unter
kleinkriminalität vorstellt klassisch
mittlerweile weiterentwickelt aber was
ich noch erzählen wollte die sz hat
geschrieben dass das ehepaar wohl
überlegt das grundbuchamt zu verklagen
das ist natürlich auch noch irgendwie
wäre noch eine lustige wende ich würde
mich jetzt schon fragen warum
ausgerechnet das grundbuchamt und nicht
einen oder beide der notare die das
beurkundet haben aber natürlich man
versuchen kann man es ja vielleicht ist
da ich würde auch nicht ausschließen
dass da noch was anhängig ist und wir
noch nicht wissen also genau wie wir
sind einige dinge in dem fall nicht das
nochmal nachgeschoben ja genau also aber
deswegen ist es trotzdem mir ein sehr
gerechtes urteil wie wir finden und wenn
es da weitere entwicklung gibt dann
halten wir sie dann halten wir euch
natürlich auf dem laufenden sind jetzt
aber am ende unserer sendung angekommen
und freuen uns
dass sie uns die stange und
für die aufmerksamkeit danken wir freuen
uns über feedback und da eigentlich
broadcast faz.de freuen uns auch über
sternchen wo man man sich hinterlassen
kann ja und hören uns dann wieder
nächste woche ihr habt eine gute woche
und bleibt uns gewogen bis dann tschüss
[Musik]